foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
just got back from the embassy had to
renew my passport two guys looked a
little younger than me recognized me
immediately it's funniest thing is
Swedish to people again especially in
Tokyo I see more Swedish people yeah it
went well okay you should bark at Momo
can do
boom
this is my closet and I'm thinking about
putting my console in here build a shelf
put a screen put speakers some lights
paint it and then we should have a home
arcade in my closet
we'll see how it actually goes
you comfy again
you look comfy
all right this is the progress so far I
got the Shelf up
it's nice I'm still waiting for the
screen and I want the speakers to be
more aimed up
so I might 3D print something for it
all right 3D print is done
let's see if it fits
hey look at that Momo has been scared of
walking the stairs but she can totally
walk though she just doesn't want to do
it or she's scaring them if she's on top
oh my god
oh you're so scared of the series
that was terrifying for you from the top
mama
you can do it
oh now it's a different ball game huh
[Music]
come in
you did it how did she do it and then
all of a sudden forget that she knows
how to do it let's start from two all
right
[Music]
thank you
update on the closet thing I put panels
in it looks nice right now I'm routing
and I Can't Do It Outdoors because it's
been raining and it's just been raining
and raining so I'm doing it in my office
don't do it in your office I had to make
my own sort of thing so I can get it
straight I bought the cheapest router
because it was smaller I deeply regret
it it's trash I hate routing it's the
first time I do it but I have one more
of these [__] out of eight and then
I'm done so it looks good in there
though
[Music]
all right so I'm testing out the lights
seems okay yeah it looks good
I have to tread eight six more
I really have to jam them in there but I
think I'll be done today
finally all the cables are still there
I'll have to fix that and the roof
but it'll look like
this you can see how bad I routed if you
look close like it's not super straight
it was hard to do but I think it yeah
I'm happy with it if I were to hack a
game and have my own controller and
arcade at home
this is how I would do it but I wouldn't
anyway I'm very pleased to have this
whole turnout and it was a nightmare to
set up but I think it turned my closet
into something really cool and useful
made possible by minimalist game get on
it
[Music]
today we're going uh Marcia's taking me
out on a little date we're almost there
it's supposed to be really cool because
we'll be at the rooftop and if you're
lucky I guess there will be clouds
forming on the Terrace so we'll be
eating amongst the clowns it doesn't
look like there's clouds to be honest
that will be cherry blossoms
[Music]
it's so fancy
can you see the clowns
hello man
they made a solute version sorry boy
very nice
[Music]
Tokyo FM Saturday night let's go
why are there flares on the ground
I've never seen that
those are flares right again
if you were a well
you would be welshia
check this out Momo has a dead giveaway
when she's gonna attack
don't pull your ears back before you
attack because then I'll know okay
don't pull your ears back
I know and you're gonna do it I know
when you're gonna do it don't pull your
ass back
[Music]
good morning I'm waiting outside as
normal for much yet to do her health
checkup with her and the baby I figured
I should share you know good and bad
because we didn't get good results last
about 10 days ago it makes it makes you
worried it she's fine and the baby's
fine but she's in the risk just at the
edge of the risk of premature labor at
least from where she is
buy a Weekly Standard so she's been
taking it very easily easy for the past
10 days not moving and trying to lay
down and not put pressure and all that
stuff so hopefully that has made a
positive change and she's been able to
catch up sort of where she's supposed to
be I'm supposed to travel tomorrow and I
don't really feel comfortable leaving
her if it's at risk you know
so it's difficult
I really hope really hope for good
results now I'll let you guys know how
it goes
[Music]
hey remember when I said I was going to
get my passport
well they didn't have it I'm supposed to
fly tomorrow but I finally got it so we
had to delay the flight a day everything
is fine with March as well by the way so
that's good I feel much more comfortable
going but I am I was supposed to meet my
parents and all that but I am just going
super quick
because Marsha still needs to rest so I
don't want to leave her too long every
time I go to the Embassy in Sweden it
becomes like a little fan Meetup I just
get recognized instantly it's really
funny I'm gonna enjoy my last day here
and then I'm off to UK
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
how do people live like this
it's 12 30 a.m I slept for
another two hours and a half the shoot
is starting so it's starting now so
it's exciting what a weird day not to be
cheeky like that but it is times like
these where you are really blind
you have a GPU
[Music]
we did it we survived that was intense
we're not allowed to say what it was
but it was very cool and finally we were
the fastest ones gay Marines the real
games
that's so cool you'll see it soon it's 5
a.m We Rent the shoot at three three a.m
so I just took a bath I had so much fun
I am so glad I went on this trip like
the flight is ridiculous and the fact
that I'm flying today
it's kind of insane but worth it that
was a memory oh I'm so happy that was so
worth it I'm so glad I mean PJ got to
hang out I'm gonna have breakfast in
like two hours because they're opening
up and then I saw because you guys know
I've been into bouldering lately I
thought there's a really good place like
20 minutes from here and my flight is
not until seven so
I might I might check it out compare
Japan and UK it's supposed to be really
good and I've never seen such high
reviews I can't help myself it's so fun
yeah so we'll check that out
thank you
[Music]
John like hit me now so hard I'm heading
back already I knew it was gonna be a
intense trip it's really fun it's just
like now I'm just like
so I arrived yesterday and I'm leaving
today
obviously I had such a good time but I
look forward to go back home now
I was doing totally fine like bouldering
shoot I didn't sleep anything but now
the receptionist told me
good morning even though it was 4 P.M
because I think she just looked at me
and saw how tired I was and then she was
like oh I'm so sorry I'm like yeah
you're right it is good morning
foreign
[Music]
it's been a while actually we haven't
done much because my RCS has just been
not moving but you've been really good
so we're doing an exhibition which looks
really cool we'll check it out walk
slowly
[Music]
come here
all right we're at stump number two to
check out some wisteria it looks really
popular but it looks very pretty we knew
it was going to be busy actually good
luck getting a photo
[Music]
thank you
they were serious it wasn't so good
[Music]
we got for free
it's all flowing into here it smells so
much
[Music]
foreign
another day waiting for myself to do her
appointment to check on our baby I think
it might be time to tell you guys the
gender
whoa there's Mount Fuji holy [__]
I'm driving
to fujikyo this is kind of crazy because
I was gonna meet up with Jimmy and Mr
B's I thought it was next month
and then today he wrote me uh I'll see
you tomorrow and I was like oh [__]
I I didn't realize you were here so soon
but he wrote me see you tomorrow at 1am
so I woke up and started thinking it's
tomorrow so I'm at Fuji Q he rented out
the whole park I didn't realize it was
actually buying Fuji that's so cool I
was supposed to be there two hours ago
but we finally figured out it was under
it was happening today this feels very
bizarre
to be doing I was not it was not what I
was planning to do in my afternoon
rather it's six now so the park is
closed
and uh yeah I wonder what it's gonna
look like
holy did you enjoy the Vlog over me
vlogging
I didn't Vlog anything my my voice is
ruined it feels weird uh filming
someone that you met for the first time
you know it was cool Jim was cool
everyone on the cruise really nice
that's a good time
the roller coaster was insane
Fuji Q is no joke like I thought for a
second I was gonna lose it it was so
scary I'm still kind of shocked about
how scary that roller coaster was you
hear my voice I can barely talk yeah
that was a weird experience
in a good way uh so I guess I'll be part
of a Mr Beast video this is one out of
six things that he's doing and for a
video I'm working on like a video where
I'm
3D printing a couple cute things
that's what I'm doing it's kind of crazy
the difference
glad I got to meet him and uh his crew
good they all seem really like really
good people
uh it's 10 30 now I'm driving home and
[Music]
all right so I got a bunch of fruit left
over from the shoot yesterday so these
are 11 per strawberry 11 more or less
and these smarts are just that are cheap
mushrooms strawberries we're gonna do a
taste test
oh
I like it
okay
the biting that one
mm-hmm that last one was the expensive
one I could tell because it was so much
cleaner to bite into but this one tasted
had more flavor I think they're more
ripe maybe I don't know if that makes
sense so I think it's more personal
preference honestly
foreign
baby in here
what would you say if we went to Pink
Cafe
because we
[Music]
thank you
I got drama guys
[Music]
oh no
yeah yeah
yeah
small Monica
mine say it's very popular
[Music]
next location is Tokyo Tower and there a
gender reveal awaits if you know you
will know
[Music]
big surprise we're having a fish
if you know what these means then you
know the gender
[Music]
thank you